[Music]
okay so this
is the xiaomi 12s
ultra it's a smartphone sure but i think
we can all tell it's all about the
camera i mean look at this thing almost
half the back of the phone is this
massive camera module the first 20 pages
of their website for this thing is all
camera camera camera stuff before it
talks about anything else they even have
this video on their site of it morphing
from a camera into this phone and it has
the world's largest smartphone camera
sensor inside can you imagine being the
person at a party where everyone's got
their phones they're like hey we want to
take a group picture does anybody have a
good smartphone camera
and you just
yeah that's
i got it i guess what i'm trying to say
is
this phone better have a great camera
[Music]
so there's been quite a bit of hype
around this brand new xiaomi 12s ultra
recently so i had to give it a shot the
headline that caught my eye about it is
that it's rocking the world's largest
smartphone camera with a one inch sensor
but a couple funny things about that
first one inch sensors aren't actually
one inch they're a little smaller than
that i actually did a video where i
talked about that i'll break that down
down in the description i'll have a link
below the like button you can check it
out but second
it's not the first smartphone with a one
inch sensor matter of fact there's been
a couple before but it is the first one
with sony's new imx 989 sensor which is
the first one built for a smartphone
camera rather than repurposing a
one-inch sensor to go into a smartphone
uh so it technically beats samsung to
the punch who we know they're working on
their iso cell camera that's going to be
a one inch sensor probably coming to the
galaxy s 23 ultra sometime next year so
xiaomi beat them to the punch and as a
matter of fact that's kind of the whole
point of this phone is to one-up
samsung's ultra phone in as many ways as
possible and to slap the same exact name
on it so you know they they can do it
better that's the statement they're
making so when i got my hands on this
phone that's what i wanted to find out
does it actually beat the king of the
hill galaxy s22 ultra at its own game
and most importantly is it actually
worth it to have the world's largest
smartphone camera
by the way it's this one not this one in
the middle that's the ultra wide and
it's not this bottom one here that's the
5x telephoto that one
that one is the world's largest
smartphone sensor so i've taken quite a
few photos and videos over the past few
days testing this phone's camera in both
normal conditions and crazy more and
more extreme conditions at its limits
and it turns out
yeah this camera is phenomenally capable
and is really really good very often so
the 50 megapixel main camera kicks out
great detail and sharpness bending down
to 12 and a half megapixels and has a
knack for reeling in exposure even in
harsh conditions taking photos into the
sun and with high dynamic range and all
that but what i really noticed is two
main things that were s tier that made
good photos really really good on this
phone and that's the shutter speed and
the auto focus are consistently really
fast because that huge sensor lets in so
much light here so for taking pictures
of moving objects like kids and vehicles
you know pets sprinting around a studio
with endless energy all that stuff it's
great and that's awesome it freezes the
action and nails focus
very reliably and that is super
confidence inspiring in a camera it also
handled low light very well which
shouldn't surprise me given the light
gathering ability of a huge sensor but i
did decide to do a little head-to-head
against the phone it's trying to one-up
so bad galaxy s22 ultra so i did a blind
side by side on twitter i should have
done a poll but just based on reading
the replies a lot of you guys really did
actually prefer the 12s ultra shot here
despite it being more saturated mostly
because it reeled in the bloom from the
street light better thanks to better
lens coatings etc and it still kept all
the details on the rest of the exposure
and had very low noise you might have
noticed the leica branding up in the
corner on the back of the phone they did
actually have some help from leica on
the optics and the coating over the
glass to reduce things like fringing and
chromatic aberration and it works great
but also the color science so when you
first fire it up the phone asks you if
you want to shoot with like a authentic
look or the leica vibrant look basically
you can think of them as the same thing
as photographic styles on the iphone the
authentic look is a little less
saturated while the vibrant kicks out a
more instantly shareable traditional
look but neither of them are
particularly great to my eye now that
i've shot with both
so yeah the typical photo from the 12s
ultra is a clean and sharp shot with
shallow depth of field for close-up
subjects pretty punchy and saturated
usually and with a lot of dynamic range
but here is my hot take on this camera
though while it isn't perfect
it has the highest ceiling of any camera
i have ever seen in a smartphone so it
doesn't always hit but when it does
it is amazing i have two shots i want to
show you that specifically just
make me feel very strongly about this so
the first one i was up on the roof of
this building there's some plants up
there it's windy up on the roof and so
i'm taking a picture of these plants and
they're moving quickly in and out of the
frame i'm just sort of like pointing and
shooting and boom the photo i get back
is this tack sharp shot with incredibly
shallow depth of field and this immense
dynamic range the movement is completely
frozen in time like the plants aren't
even moving i kind of couldn't believe
it just seeing how fast the stuff was
moving around in and out of the frame
it's a shock that autofocus even worked
but it locked on it kept it in focus and
it nailed it and it did it again and
again and over and over again and then
the other one is uh i was at practice
the other day
way out on an island somewhere i put my
cleats on i was just about to put my
phone back in my bag but i took a photo
of the ground and just like my cleats on
the ground before i got up boom and with
this one
this isn't even a particularly difficult
shooting condition right it's not much
moving it's just a still subject of my
feet but optically
this might be the most impressive photo
i have ever seen come out of a
smartphone camera keep in mind there is
no portrait mode here this is normal
depth of field my cleats are tack sharp
there's a clear shallow depth of field
and you can see the slight roll-off of
the blur getting stronger and stronger
the further you go back in the frame and
the exposure and the contrast and the
color of the entire shot are all so nice
so you know it's just a random
off-center snap of my feet but jesus
from a phone
i kind of love this photo so i've said a
lot of good things about this camera but
i also said it wasn't perfect so it's a
flagship i'm gonna pixel peep and i'm
gonna go through those things too it
does have some of the more classic
weaknesses of a big sensor smartphone
like this so the huge sensor makes for a
nice natural depth of field which we
know is awesome it's amazing for those
mid-range shots like two to four feet
away but when you get too close it
definitely definitely starts to fringe
like any other smartphone with a huge
sensor so you can get close up to a
subject and there's real blur but often
part of the subject is in focus and then
some of it isn't and the blur is pretty
ugly when this happens now they try to
combat this like a lot of others do by
auto switching to macro mode which comes
from the ultra wide camera unfortunately
the ultrawide camera has a dramatically
different
look and color science to it it just
looks so different overall and in my
opinion it looks worse it solves the
fringing problem but yeah it looks worse
and then speaking of color science it is
dramatically inconsistent between the
lenses you can easily see if you just
quickly switch between them like go from
4.9 x to 5.2 x there's a pretty big
difference in color
in exposure in contrast in everything
and the same thing happens in the
ultrawide this is a pretty common thing
with smartphones but it's particularly
bad here and then the video footage the
videos are typically pretty good you can
shoot up to 8k 24fps from any of the
lenses or 4k 30 which looks pretty solid
when it hits focus especially with that
rock solid image stabilization but it
has this weird bug and it took me a
minute to figure out what was going on
because i shot a ton of videos and i was
trying to understand here so
stay with me right so i go up to the
roof again i'm taking videos of the
skyline and i see a plane and i'm going
to go i'm going to i'm going to test
this feature where i can switch between
all three lenses while zooming through
video cool that you can do that right so
i pointed out the plane and i start
taking this video and what i think i'm
doing and what i see in the viewfinder
is i zoom all the way in on the plane
and then i track it across the sky
perfectly keeping it in the center of
the viewfinder
so imagine my surprise
when this is the clip that comes out of
the shot it starts by zooming in on the
plane
but then
uh it looks like like i fell asleep
while recording or something like it
totally leaves the frame and so i
literally just got the shot and then
went and watched it back and i saw that
it wasn't what i thought i had i was
trying to figure this out
turns out what i believe is happening
is as you're smoothly zooming in and out
switching between the three lenses while
recording
the viewfinder
is just smoothly zooming in on the
primary sensor
and so when it showed me that i was
keeping the camera keeping the plane in
the middle of the frame
what it was actually doing
was switching
to the telephoto in the recording so you
can actually see while watching the
footage the moment that it switches to
the telephoto camera which has a
slightly different angle to it so at the
max zoom that really adds up quite a bit
so what i'm seeing on the screen is not
what i'm actually recording this is
something that i think they can fix
pretty easily with software by just
adjusting
where the zoom happens but it's just an
odd i don't know it's a quirk if you
happen to be doing a lot of super zoomed
in creepy videos of stuff far away then
you should know that this one might you
need to you need to calibrate or adjust
for it but anyway there's so much more i
could go into with this camera from the
optical lens emulation from a couple old
lenses to all the various modes there's
a super moon mode and a
multi-video angle mode a whole bunch of
other stuff but i think the summary with
this gigantic camera on this smartphone
is
the hits
really hit
it's hit or miss
but the hits
hit hard it is a fascinating
optical experience shooting with this
phone the rest of the phone by the way
is very much ultra like again they're
taking aim directly at samsung here so
i'm talking snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 chip
with 12 gigs of ram which is now a few
months ahead of samsung making that leap
it has a 6.7 inch 1440p 120 hertz oled
display ltpo which is 522 pixels per
inch with a max brightness of 1500 nits
it's a world-class display aside from
the curved sides and corners which i'm
starting to hate there's also a
4860 milliamp hour battery which isn't
the biggest but with 67 watt fast
charging 50 watt wireless charging and
10 watt reverse wireless charging all
better than samsung's flagship the
speakers are excellent and dolby atmos
certified and with plenty of eq settings
to match there's a new x-axis haptic
motor which is great and it's all
wrapped in a build combining matte black
metal and
faux leather that's ip68 water resistant
and looks like a minion
just gonna be honest
looks like a minion you will most likely
never see this phone in real life if you
live in the united states or north
america
but in the regions that xiaomi is
selling it in it goes for about 900
which again is one upping or better than
what samsung selling their ultra for
so as far as their mission
i'd say mission accomplished
the me 12s ultra xiaomi mi 12s ultra
is a really impressive phone the hits
hit so hard i love this thing
anyway let me know what you think that's
been it thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace